This is an example. So this is applications both
in.
linear programming
And by extension, it has applications
and economics in finance and
transportation or Logistics.
And so look at what we've done here again, we've we're using
row operations. So we for example
add one equation to the other equation or
we multiply one equation to another equation or a
multiply one equation with some number and then
add it to another equation.
If you do this by hand, it is very cumbersome.
Okay, the linear example, I still linear program
example actually was very trivial it was we only had two because here
we have three and even in this case you have to do a lot
of addition subtraction multiplication to eventually find the
route. So here are the roots X is equal to 2 Y is equal to negative one is equal
to 3 and it's called the reduced row Echelon form because
look here.
what happens is that in order to know that
you've actually found the solution or
the roots for all three equations or the
roots for all of these variables is you get this form you
get this diagonal form you can you
see how we have why excuse me one across the principle diagonal
When your Matrix looks like this, let me
zoom in.
When your Matrix looks like this or you have one in
the first row and zero zero then one in the second row
in the middle.
Hey this diagonal basically, once your Matrix looks like that
you can then substitute the values back into your equation.
So for example X Phase 1 to become
zero three becomes zero.
And now it becomes two. This is how you would what I
found the roots of your
A roots of these of all three equations. And again
I said, this is important. Why because let's say
you have multiple models.
again Financial modeling, for example
If we said that a model is supposed to be representation not
necessarily technical precise representation,
but representation on the
less.
So models which come the form of equations most of
the time if you were to find the roots of those
equations, then you would have understood why this
model behaves a certain way.
Okay.
The the the model the equation for force
is one example Force equals mass times acceleration, okay.
So if you're able to find the roots, then you can get to
the essence of the model and then you can use that to for
regression and machine learning.
okay, so in the real world you actually have
you have to handle multiple models at
the same time.
And linear algebra gives us techniques for that. Now I
said earlier that this is very cumbersome to
do like you have to do a lot of manual arithmetic which brings us to
python.
with python we can't solve systems of
linear equations like this
almost instantaneously
so we don't have to do this by hand, but we still want to
have the capability to do it.
So what we will do is we can we can do
linear programming.
in
you know a large.
sets of equations on large sets of constraints
with a library like numpy.
Okay. Anyway, this was supposed to give you a glimpse into.
the first part of
The first let's say have of linear
algebra, which I said.
is systems of linear equations